alors où nous nous parlons pas de
décision à ce stade sur la livraison de
Charles aéroport donc le léopard à
l'Ukraine on en parle avec vous Caroline
de Camaret vous êtes notre spécialiste
justement des questions européennes ça
tombe bien les Ukrainiens demandent donc
aux Européens de monter en puissance sur
ces livraisons d'armes oui d'abord c'est
c'est effectivement le président Zélande
qui lui-même qui s'est adressé à
Rammstein à l'ensemble des Occidentaux
qu'ils soutiennent leur demandant
d'accélérer les livraisons d'armes pour
arrêter le mal ce sont ces mots et pour
le Kremlin et bien ces charges
occidentaux ne changeront rien sur le
terrain c'est leur déclaration mais
c'est pas tout à fait vrai ça pourrait
faire une vraie différence à tel point
que les pays européens bien finalement
on fait on fait des annonces ces
dernières 24 heures très importantes le
Danemark par exemple qui a créé la
surprise en annonçant 19 canons César
qu'il allait livrer à l'Ukraine c'est
presque autant que la livrer la France
qui est le fabricant de ces canons la
Suède a décidé de livrer ses can qui
sont un peu les mêmes et puis le
Royaume-Uni effectivement
600 missiles guidés anti-charbre remston
14 chars etc vous avez compris que la
Finlande elle par exemple elle elle veut
elle elle a mis plus d'argent sur la sur
la table mais le nerf de la guerre c'est
bien le char la Pologne et la Finlande
ont déclaré qu'elles enverraient les
chars les fameux chars allemands léopard
à l'Ukraine si l'Allemagne donne son
accord parce que il y a le problème du
transfert de technologie pour tout
transfert il faut l'accord du
constructeur allemand le on considère
que le léopard 2 est très bien très bien
à la libilité à aller sur ce type de
terrain de guerre alors c'est pour ça
que hier le secrétaire américain à la
Défense a mis une pression maximale sur
Berlin et le tout nouveau ministre de la
Défense Boris pistorus qui remplace une
ministre qui elle c'était quelque peu
ridiculiser dans le poste et l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui vous le disiez est toujours
réticente par crainte d'une escalade de
Moscou dit-elle à la fois à livrer
elle-même des chars et à donner des
autorisations et ça commence à agacer
sérieusement les Européens on sait en
Allemagne depuis le début de cette
guerre avait déjà été réticente au
départ mais jusqu'à présent du point de
vue européen les Européens sont quand
même en deçà des attentes des Ukrainiens
oui alors c'est à dire que si on compare
vraiment en matière d'équipement l'armée
américaine soutient massivement même si
là effectivement elle hésite elle aussi
à livrer ses chars soutien massivement
et si on regarde en espèces sonnante et
trébuchante elle est à 26,7 milliards de
dollars d'aide militaire total des
États-Unis mais si on prend l'ensemble
des Européens l'Union européenne et
chacun des États membres on est autour
de 9-10 milliards donc c'est trois fois
moins mais c'est vraiment ce sont
vraiment quand même des sommes non
négligeables pour certains l'Union doit
aller jusqu'au bout prendre de ses
responsabilités faire du quoi qu'il en
coûte parce qu'en face et bien Moscou
fait un quoi qu'il en coûte en chair
humaine en chair à canon et c'est le cas
de la présidente du Parlement européen
Roberta mezzola qui nous parlait de
cette nécessité d'aider l'Ukraine dans
une interview à Strasbourg on l'écoute
moi je suis en contact régulier avec mes
collègues au crâniennes ils ont besoin
de beaucoup d'aide de beaucoup de
financement vous avez évoqué le 18
milliards 3000 milliards de déjà
m'envoyer hier voter aussi ici dans ce
Parlement mais aussi il y a besoin
beaucoup d'aide logistiquement dans
cette période très difficile mais sans
électricité sans chauffage sans sans les
services essentiels mais aussi il y aura
besoin d'aide militaires et c'est pour
ça que dans ce Parlement il y a toujours
des discussions pour continuer à aider
les Ukrainiennes qui maintenant ils
ils bataille pour nous et le bataille
pour nos espoirs nos libertés les
valeurs que pour nous tous sont communs
le crâne doivent gagner la guerre
on n'a pas de choix on n'a pas de choix
alors on n'a pas le choix pour Roberta
mezzola la présidente du Parlement
européen qui est notre grande invité
pour ici l'Europe ce samedi à 12h10 ne
la manquez pas elle nous parle aussi
d'un autre scandale le Qatar gate qui
secoue effectivement l'Union européenne
merci beaucoup Karine de Camara retrouvé
sur l'antenne de France 24 et aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux merci